El Salvador's now been living in a state
of emergency for more than three months
as the government tries to dismantle the
country's gangs
full rights suspended as authorities
detained tens of thousands
and that state of emergency's just been
extended for another month by a congress
dominated by the ruling party
they say that won't be the end of it
we'll do it as many times as is
necessary we're going to approve it
until we finish off the last gang member
in the country
to you many Salvadorans support that
this is a country in which whole
neighborhoods have suffered extortion
rape and killing over decades at the
hands of gangsters called maras the
human rights organizations say the
arrests have been incredibly arbitrary
and can be based on nothing more than a
tattoo or living in the wrong part of
town
and we've seen Mass hearings where
judges are ruling on the fate of
hundreds of people at a time meaning
that they don't have the right to a
proper defense we've seen violations of
the presumption of innocence
and we've even spoken to judges and
other members of the justice system
about attacks on the judicial system and
they they told us that they've been
getting pressure from above not to
acquit anybody
as a result El Salvador's prisons are so
packed that the government's planning to
build new ones
[Music]
for one percent of El Salvador's
population is now in prison which means
it's overtaken the U.S to hold the
world's highest incarceration rate uh
We've documented cases of torture and
ill treatment inside detention centers
but El Salvador's President says he's
only going to get tougher after the
killing of three police officers in an
ambush on Tuesday
the gang members are stupid we're not
going to back down we are not even going
to stay the same what we are going to do
is intensify this war against gangs
questions over both whether that will
work other Salvadoran governments have
also tried to crack down hard without
success and how many Innocents will be
left in the country's prisons when this
is over
John Holman Al Jazeera